today I want you to get excited hey guys
it's time to know the book update and
I'm on my way to whole foods and I'm
excited you know last week I missed my
writing day because I was in New Orleans
speaking at a conference for sage and
and I'm I'm just ready to go right now
I'm so excited I can't wait to get the
whole foods and answer your questions
here on this video and just start
banging it out the end is near we're
working down on the last section of the
book and I and I don't know I'm just
really excited about going and right in
thinking about my excitement and I can't
wait to get there it kind of reminds me
of a business and a lot of you guys it's
important to keep the momentum going in
your business and it's important to get
excited you know I'm not saying every
day you're going to be always pumped and
super excited for your business but if
you are not excited for too long in your
business then something's wrong then you
got to change it you gotta shake it up
you got to tap back into whatever you're
passionate about and transform your
business so that's something that you
can get excited by because if you are
not excited about your business then
you're never going to do anything great
with it okay so this week the message is
get excited now over to your questions
first up Tamara weeks who asked evan are
you behind on writing because of the
conference so I'm a little bit behind we
have a schedule too I have to have the
book in the publishers hands by
mid-october and so we sell a few weeks
left to kind of wrap it up and then do
all the final tuning of it so put me a
little bit behind but not too much I
still have a little I self some time
left before I have to to get it in but
the clock is ticking and I gotta get it
in soon next up ed who wrote in to say
hey I mean I developed a business model
for an advertising business there's one
major flaw which is a dependent on other
people being honest I like to live in a
bubble and believe that everyone is
honest at the moment I'm not sure which
path to take first go ahead with this
model and risked getting burned so I can
change them all and illuminate my faults
and turn into every other agency thanks
Evan you are great and if I never saw
your videos I would never become an
entrepreneur well first off I appreciate
the last part of that message that means
a lot to me you know I put a lot of love
and energy into this channel and do a
few guys in here that you or your
inspired be an entrepreneur because of
me touches me man made my day super
excited to thank you for that to answer
your question it's a tough one because I
believe it honestly too and I like to
work with honors clients and honest team
members and I've you know I've set
myself up to potentially be burned you
know the people on my team I don't track
what they do right I don't track their
hours I don't I don't micromanage them
and so they could be screwing me over
all day long I'll do work with clients
before I get paid sometimes and because
I trust in a relationship ok so my iPad
cut out because arrived a space had to
delete some old pictures and videos and
here we are finishing the answer so I've
been very rarely burned by people who
aren't being honest but I've also done a
lot of screening in advance and do small
starts before actually getting start on
the bigger project so I think your model
can work but on a limited scale what I
mean by that is if you're working with a
select few people that you screen and
you build good relationship with and I
think it can work if you're trying to
build something much bigger if you're
trying to build something where you
don't even know who your customers are
and you're building like a web model
around it then I think you could be
setting yourself up for some failure and
some negative expectations and so I just
try to guard against that I'd also try
to look for is there a way that you
might be able to merge the two you know
could honestly be a part of it but then
there's still a way to the check in
report and you know if you look at ebay
success story and how they started
pierre omidyar said that he believes
people are good in general people are
good and he trusts people to to deliver
the package right i mean a big part of
ebay is i'm spending money on something
will they actually ship me the product
that i'm spending the money on and so he
believes that most people are good but
you're going to have a few bad apples
and as long as you can mitigate the bad
apples and ebay does it through reviews
and ratings and if you can have that
kind of system setup then i think it can
work for you next up is isaac how to
meet the right woman for an
in our life wow that's a hard question
and okay I'll tell you my personal story
I always believe that it's hard for
somebody to understand an entrepreneur
if you're not an entrepreneur and my
first real relationship lasted about
five years and was with a girl who
didn't understand business didn't
understand entrepreneurship didn't
understand what was happening in my
company and little things like you know
if I had to go do something if I had to
go speak in an event you know she
wouldn't come out to support and you
know it just made me feel like I was on
my own I was doing it all on my own and
obviously we hung out and and you know
afterwards but I felt alone and so after
that relationship ended I thought
thought well maybe I need to be with
another entrepreneur you'll be with
somebody who who's doing it herself
because she'll understand me she'll
understand what I'm going through and
the next relation from within i actually
married this woman who had her own
business and how all we ended up doing
was talking about business my business
her business and it was very stimulating
intellectually but after five years we
ended up getting divorced and what I
found out was we ended up being much
better business partners business
advisors to each other then gotcha
coming through we'd not be much better
business partners and visors than we did
mean in a romantic relationship and that
was a interesting lesson to learn then I
didn't really have a strategy of do I
want to be with an entrepreneur not an
entrepreneur I was just trying to find
somebody that I loved and and I met Nina
she might be watching this video if you
are love you babe and Nina is great in
that Nina is not an entrepreneur and I
don't know if she would ever have the
gumption to start her own business she
works a typical job but she supports me
and everything that I'm doing and I
think the one thing that that I found
really helpful for me is to involve her
and explain what's going on I think
that's probably a mistake I made in my
first relationship with the non
entrepreneur Nina is extremely
supportive but I I don't always do the
best job and I have done more recently
just kind of explaining what's happening
telling her about the project's telling
her about what I'm worried about having
her involved in the comments right she
leaves a lot of the comments now for you
guys if she feels like she's a part of
the business she feels like she
understands what I'm going through and
she can relate and I think as an
entrepreneur it's up to you to not just
take on everything yourself but also
kind of help explain what you're going
through and get them involved in terms
of finding the right person I guess you
know I've never done the online dating
so I can't give you much experience that
there that's the right path or not one
thing that I found helpful in terms of
meeting anybody really is doing the
things that you love you know I met Nina
through salsa dancing and we have that
shared passion together and it's
something that we both enjoy doing and
it developed into a relationship and so
I would just start doing the things that
you love to do and you'll end up meeting
the people that have similar interests
but make sure again that you're open and
you're explaining what's happening in
your company and yeah let's help me and
hopefully I can help you next up dread
dog thanks to this video and to my
question my next question is do you
think it'd be a good idea to start a
channel the tracks my journey towards my
goal we're just starting my own business
I think would help keep me motivated and
show others that if I can do it so can
they thanks again and can't wait through
your book when is published thank you
man I appreciate the book support I am
excited to get it out there in people's
hands and hopefully change some lives
taste your question first of all i think
is a great idea i think it's a great
idea to track your journey one for you
to see how far you've come you know a
lot of people don't realize how how many
steps you've actually taken forward
we're all they see is I haven't got the
results i want i don't have the momentum
i need yet i'm not where i want to be
I'm not making enough money and I have a
big enough impact yet I do that too
right like I want to be I should be
doing better I should have a million
subscribers on my channel i right we
criticized as we look forward but we
don't realize the success that we've
already had when we look back and so I
think having a journey and documenting
it would be super helpful and motivating
for others but also for you you know
when I look back at my old videos I'm
I'm shocked like wow those are some bad
videos that was really bad and so yes
I'm not at you know a million
subscribers yet but I'm Way better than
I was before and having that journey
helps helps me feel more motivated and
like I'm making some good progress son
is on my face when they split the hat
around
as that go jays go so my second part of
that is are you into video you know
that's a skill that you want to learn is
that something that you find interesting
you guys certainly youtube channel got
into video is not probably going to be
the best idea for you but you can start
a blog if you like writing or you can
follow it on twitter if you like the
tweet so do what you like to do and and
put that into the content format that
works best for you the other thing I'd
say is you'll get better right if you
want to learn that as a skill being good
on camera that's a great way to do it
this is just just to start doing it stop
thinking about it and start doing it and
be consistent with it and over time if
you look back you'll find that hey not
only is your business growing but you're
getting better on camera as well and
then the last part about inspiring
people I love that man why am I doing
this book series why do I keep track of
what's happening with my book it's
motivate me but also hopefully motivate
you and that you know life happens I
don't have all the answers I'm making
mistakes I'm sharing my process my ups
and downs and you guys are joining me
for the journey and I think it's
hopefully inspiring other people to want
to do something bigger with their lives
and take on big projects as well and so
if you want to join that momentum create
a new revolution yourself as well I
think it's it's fantastic because
businesses should be around to inspire
others and create social value apart
from just making money last question is
Bassam hello up and I'm struggling in my
life for the past four years without any
success until now as such as I moved to
the US as a new immigrant looking for
the American dream I'm fresh off the
boat have a language barrier and the new
culture also I don't know how to develop
myself and set goals I feel like I'm
lost in life I'm 30 years old any advice
please thank you my role models yawn
clogged goddamn because he came to the
US as a new immigrant he worked as a
delivery pizza guy sorry for my bad week
writing in English that's somebody I'm
feeling your pain and
you know we all go through these periods
in our lives and we're not sure what to
do and we have these moments of crisis I
think first of all you have to recognize
that some of your thoughts are holding
you back the fact that you don't have
perfect English nobody cares about it
right van Dam didn't care about it right
he started the pizza delivery guy and
here he is you know being the superstar
that he is and I think that as long as
you feel like your English is going to
hold you back then it will you know I
understood you perfectly I'm making this
YouTube video now for you right don't
let that or any other limiting person
bleep hold you back because people will
say that I'm an immigrant I don't speak
the language I don't understand the
culture you know I don't have the
education I don't have the money I don't
have the resources whatever excuse wanna
feel is just an excuse and as long as
you hold that in your head then it's
going to prevent you from doing
something great it's going to hold you
where you are and so if you're ready to
break free what I start to thing to do
is what am i passionate about what am I
excited about what gets me going not
worrying about having the perfect plan
to there's never a perfect plan just
start doing something don't worry about
having the perfect goal right what is
that you want to do you want to be an
actor you want to be a chef do you want
to open up your own convenience store do
you want to be a software entrepreneur
like what is it that you want to do and
just start doing it and as you go you'll
find that your goals will change your
plans will change and just like I
started off at the start of this session
this video get excited what are you
excited about and go do that and don't
worry about having a perfect plan
because again it's never going to be
perfect okay you know I want you to keep
me posted I want you to keep me update I
want you to do one thing to get you
excited that maybe you felt like you can
never do because of whatever excuse you
have in your head just go out and do
that and then come back and leave a
comment post update because I want to I
want to hear about your your journey
okay man thank you guys for watching if
you have a question for me that you want
me to answer in the next edition of my
Evans book video leave it below and I'll
see what I can do thank you guys
continue to believe I'll see you soon